when you put English text into a
computer it is saving every individual
character as eight bits of data eight
ones and zeros I mean they're not
actually ones and zeros they are
particular positions of atoms on a disk
or a few electrons going over a wire but
as far as we're concerned in the
computer science world they are ones and
zeros bit and yes a modern file or
computer might store a few quadrillion
of them but every time you've had to
wait a long time for a download or your
phone has complained that its storage is
full you are running up against the same
question that computer scientists have
been working on since before these
things here was state of the art can we
please not use so many bits so let's run
through how computers compress text
images and video are different that's
lossy compression or it doesn't matter
if you lose a little bit of detail but
text has to be losslessly compressed you
can't just lose a bit of detail
otherwise you end up sending the wrong
worms so the first thing we need to know
is how text is stored on disk before
it's compressed to make this easier I'm
just going to talk about English text
here I know only too well that it gets
more complicated than this but hey this
series is called the basic so deal with
it on a modern computer each English
character takes up exactly eight ones
and zeros on disk eight bits or one byte
and there are 256 possible combinations
of those ones and zeros so you can have
256 possible characters that's enough
for being bish alphabet numbers of
punctuation and well then it gets
complicated depending on which country
you're in and oh my god that's a whole
separate video we do not want to get
into right now why 8 bits because it was
big enough to store all the characters
that American computers usually needed
but no bigger so the text doesn't take
up any more space than it absolutely has
to 8 is also a power of 2 which means
it's easy to deal with at the really low
levels of programming it's also helpful
to have a fixed number of bits per
character because it makes searching
through text really fast if you want to
go to the hundred thousandth character
and some text you know exactly where the
ones and zeros are going to be without
having to count the number of bits in
every single character before it if you
want to know how long a string of text
is you just count the bits and you
divide by eight computers don't have the
luxury
of spaces remember it's just one long
string of ones and zeros but let's say
we're not worried about speed right now
we just want to fit as much text as
possible into a smaller number of ones
and zeros as possible compression a good
plan would be to assign the most common
characters to smaller arrangements of
bits so those researchers way way back
could have said well the space bars
generally used most often just give that
the code zero then it's the lowercase e
give that the code one then it's
lowercase T give that to zeros and
immediately we have hit a problem
because the computer running through
that text later has no way of knowing
whether zero zero is at T or the
spacebar twice and if we keep on
assigning letters like that the problems
keep getting worse is three zeros a
lowercase n or a T followed by a space
or three spaces remember there are no
gaps here no actual space separators all
the computer can see is a constant
stream of ones and zeros there's no way
to know which is meant except in 1952 a
very clever mathematician called David
Huffman invented Huffman coding you
invent something like that you name gets
put on it yes there are much better more
modern more complicated mathematical
ways to do this but Huffman coding is
the basic foundation of modern text
compression and here is how it works
let's say we want to compress let's go
with the lyrics to Will Smith's wild
wild west uncompressed that is three
thousand six hundred eighty four
characters taking up nearly 30,000 bits
first up you count how many times each
character is used and you put that in a
list in order now that'll be different
for each block of text you're
compressing this has way more double use
than usual now take the two least used
characters those two are going to be the
bottom branches on your Huffman tree
write them down with how often they're
used next to them that's called the
frequency then connect them together one
level up with the sum of their
frequencies now add that new sum back
into your list where ever it's it's
higher up and repeat take the bottom two
off your list connect them up and the
result back in your list keep that going
and when one of the sons reaches the
bottom two at the list you connect it up
like that and eventually you are going
to be down to one thing in your list
right at the top you now have a Huffman
tree and it looks
this and it tells you how to convert
your text into ones and zeros our first
letter is the first uppercase W in Wicky
Wicky wild wild west uppercase W is here
that 141 of them so go to the top follow
path down each time you take the
left-hand side write a 0 each time you
take the right-hand side write a 1 so W
is this only 5 bits instead of 8 next
lowercase I follow the code down only 4
bits this times its more common than the
K which is less common that actually
takes up 7 bits and you keep going some
of the letters will take up more than 8
bits but that's fine because they're not
used very often now you do also have to
store this tree to provide a translation
table between your new symbols and the
uncompressed ones so this is not
efficient for short bits of text if
you're ever asked to do this in a
computer science exam then they will
ignore all that and just ask you to do
one easy word from a tree by hand but
for Will Smith's magnum opus we have
compressed it down to just over 20,000
bits about a 30% saving to uncompress
the resulting string of bits it works
the other way just read across take the
left fork every time you see a 0 and the
right fork every time you see a what
when you reach a letter that's it you
know that's the end and you know that
there is no other path you could
possibly have taken you start again with
the next bit now in practice computers
might do this working backwards from the
bottom up sometimes this is a pretty
good way to at least understand what's
going on and here is the really clever
part Huffman proved that this is the
most efficient way to assign zeros and
ones to single characters it is
mathematically impossible to beat this
unless as you might already have figured
out you start working on blocks bigger
than one character clever tricks like
that are basically how zip files work
but then this is just the basics thank
you to all my proofreaders who helped
with that script thank you to my
graphics team and also thank you to the
Center for computing history in
Cambridge for like a film with their old
kit